from the suburbs of Pittsburgh across
steel and coal country to the West
Virginia border the voters speak today
choosing a new congressman in a super
close special election that was once
thought to be a safe seat for the GOP I
think it says a lot about Democratic ado
guys around here Democrat Connor Lam a
former prosecutor and Marine Corps
veteran has proven his prowess drunk
significant union support and far
surpassing the fundraising of his
Republican opponent state Rep Rick
ciccone an Air Force veteran and fervent
Trump backer people wanted to evaluate
my record verses to tone records yet the
president vice president first daughter
son and top advisor all came to the 18th
district to stump for ciccone who
promises to be the president's wingman
in Washington Ciccone enthusiastically
backs the president's agenda from tax
cuts to immigration lam takes care to
avoid bashing the president and has
expressed a willingness to reach across
the aisle presenting himself as pro-gun
and an advocate for the working man both
candidates are fighting to earn support
from the largely blue-collar voters who
propelled Trump's Pennsylvania victory
in 2016 I voted for Rick Ciccone I voted
for him because I I want to continue
president Trump's agenda I I think we
need to get back to being America first
Connor Lam he's a he's a young guy he's
a veteran he's somebody that I think
will fight for our country the race is
being watched locally nationally and in
Washington where one Democratic senator
from the Keystone State says if Connor
is able to win I think it's a very it's
a very telling indicator frankly even if
he if he fell short by a couple of
points it's this is a district that Mitt
Romney won by 17 points in the president
of course
20 points so it's a very good indicator
where where people are that they want
change the results of this race are all
about the optics of momentum and which
party will get a boost heading into the
midterms the polls close tonight at 8:00
p.m.